äpfel zucker glukose fruktose morgens
einfach conti mit dem bus nehmen wir
haben wir holen noch nudeln gemüse kam
es dann auch häufig mit dem tango und
kiki krieg dir alles alles wird so angst
mit kurzen test beim masters eine frage
haben sie gut gemacht denn ehrlich also
jetzt kommt meine besonderheit fraktion
patrick frau halt sagen wir heute machen
wir eine challenge ich habe nämlich
heute einem gast beim bier und zwar die
lacher
das ist die lara wer sie noch nicht
kennt sie gibt outfit inspirationen hat
eine eigene make up linie und auch dort
viele business menschen und kleine auch
also mega mega fleißig und du bist nicht
alleine
mein mann ist noch da und ich das blut
also vor kurzem ging auf seinem kanal
ein video online mit dem review dass der
christen auch also unbedingt in der
infobox einmal abchecken und habe mir
gedacht gibt es eine richtige challenge
zwischen uns bald und groß und hamza
wehrmacht die besseren waffen genau
überlegen waren bisher challenge zutaten
und kommen wir beide wenn wir geld
einkaufen aber getrennt voneinander
gaben einige treffer und wir nehmen auch
die handys von den an
also da damit keiner googeln kam was das
waffen rezept immer genau belastung zwar
zuletzt um ich war schon einmal vor zwei
jahren und du länger aber ich hab nicht
mal für ein ok krass also irgend
eigentlich auch unvorbereitet die jungs
auch und ziel ist es wer macht einfach
das beste waffe rezept ohne vorher zu
googeln und ich würde mir eine
eingeworfen einkaufen wir müssen ein
lockeres verkaufen hierbei ist also zu
tun
ok und ihr wart ja das ist doch zu hause
auf der theke alles gut kommt die stadt
nicht einbezogen
so leute sind angekommen im kaufland ist
die challenge wir bereits fest waffel
mit top picks und antwort
das ist unsere strategie einmal
aufzulaufen
ok überrascht wir machen mal obst oder
twitter ist komplett mit pop acts wie
sonst anfang ganz lustig
also ich würde mir aber erdbeeren zu
dieser jahreszeit banane aber auf jeden
fall oder wieviel zwei stücke natürlich
absolut zu denn man kann ja so news von
den apfel appell lasst uns doch zeigen
was wir drauf haben oder oder achtes tor
bio ich achte auch bio deswegen wir
natürlich kauft als biomarker seiner
sitzung mit schokolade oder oder wollen
wir atomic machen wo wir dann wirklich
alles sein kann
sie haben ja keine anzahl wir können ja
einfach alles klar mango oder sind schon
alle gut meiner meinung nach hier und da
ist bewusst dass schokolade flüssig
machen ja man hat in der regel genau die
weiße schokolade gibt es hier
der hier geboren sind brauchen wir so
kamel brauchen backpulver puderzucker ja
auch geil oder mehr brauchen wir auf
jeden fall ne und zucker auch aber nicht
weizenmehl normale mir das geht so oben
gehen das alles ist braucht das ist
unser zuhause das weiß ich ja aber die
sollen ja alles kaufen sagt sie
wo ist backpulver kommt dann muss man so
eine männerabteilung nachdem das
banalste dann waren halt sahne ist purer
vandalismus
hier brauchen wir bestimmt die dann
sagen wir können ja mal beim apfelmus
hier gucken was die da drin montag ist
auch hier bestimmt und milch milch
kommen auf jeden fall rein
ein priester wie immer bei diesen sachen
wetzel zucker glukose fruktose
zahlungsmittel zitronensäure
antioxidantien der halle alles auf
zucker gegen vorstoffen genau apple
haben wir auch etwas zitrone
zitrone und oder zitronen abgibt der
also auch in die biotonne okay aber
natürlich kenne ich doch einfach noch
einen trick lassen und ein absolutes ko
aber kommt wo wir machen die app klein
schneiden und hier bin ich okay da muss
noch gibt
mit vereinfachten weltkirche damals von
meiner mutter abgepackte drei doppel
getan er hilft dann habe ich mich
hingesetzt und bei zdf dass diese
programme glaube ich halbe stunde lang
war ich dann folgt aktiv wird nicht mehr
alters scheiße ich muss in die küche
dann gehe ich in die kirche als es
geschah nichts dafür was ich hasse
darauf besteht vom koffer gehobener
fenster geöffnet der dürfen da hat so
ein buch genommen meine mutter gegen
heraus und meinte ich bin heute abend zu
hause will dass meine küche genauso
aussieht wie ich sie verlassen haben die
ganzen wende waren wirklich schwarz oder
weiß 13 oder 14
und dann wirken ja so diese stücke nach
oben drauf
nein damit man abgeben
ihr habt mir gleich überhaupt uns im
internet nachzuschauen dadurch nicht wie
keine magazin oder dass die industrie
erst nach magazin abteilungen 104 114
morgens einfach und die diskussion ist
die bekommt erst nach bestehen auf jeden
fall der zettel wenn er noch leben würde
vermehren wird der milch dann steht man
auch hallo wo ist denn hier der
abteilung hier back abteilung
auch immer du bist danke mutter in steht
wir haben es jetzt gemacht der fertigung
wir haben hier wirklich haben wir
salzgitter
wir haben wir holen nur mogeln bin auch
nie verbogen
wir sind auf jeden fall fertig wir haben
uns gedacht wir machen drei oder vier
sorgen und dem topic 1 dann so atomic
alles mögliche anrufs rein untersander
und apfelmus wie am extra äpfel gekauft
also die mädels raten auto wären wir
schon mal eingekauft haben
nicht gucken haben die kugel einfach
jetzt nicht die wir dran das so lustig
wir haben auch nicht gesehen was wir
jetzt ein gekaufter also erstmal
brauchen die butter vom 1
dann über das gesetz zu kopfe später
dann wollten wir glaube ich kirchen aus
der dose kaufen müssen wir dann auch die
speisestärke nochmal kaum als hauptgang
alle sahne damit wir die aufschlagen
brauchen wir dafür bei nicht ob ich dann
gucken was noch als ob ich kann mich
hier jährlich aus
du weißt ja was wir wo steht ja ich für
dich ist keine hilfen teilung
ok also wir glauben dass die jungs nicht
auf die idee mit den heißen kirschen
kommen frage ob die machen einfach basic
süßigkeit die machen sagen und dann
schauen diese strecke also irgendwie
sollten wir wollen dass er wirklich wie
im restaurant hafen mit so heißen
kirschen extra in schale sondern ich
noch mikado lehm und dann können wir
dann zieht immer richtig gute comedy
nennt ja okay dann nehmen wir die weißen
endlich was dem einkaufswagen
ich bin fasziniert von eurem kauf
einfach keine rolltreppen die andere
abteilung ab jetzt komme ich hier ist
das freiland kontrollieren genau
unternehmen eine schlagsahne und somit
auch legal begann geil sondern das
nehmen wir beides nehmen denn die dann
kommt ja wieder führen hier ja dann
nehmen wir das auch nicht schwanger und
bisschen arbeit
take that oder verspricht auch nicht
schnell sind die die man hier doch so
ganz wichtig so jetzt noch eine packung
seiner festrede speisestärke dafür sein
dass es zwei gegenwart kurve einfach
vergessen es sind so viele sachen später
machen
hallo mainz zwei gänge weiter
speisestärke 100 sekunde wird blieben
die mit den herrn seehofer für die
kirche
jetzt weiß ich warum gehen so lang
gebraucht haben letzter stopp die ice
abteilung dann ganz schnell als nummer
wir konnten uns keinen besseren
zeitpunkt aussuchen als
freitagnachmittag einkaufen zu gehen
sonst nicht aber die lager verloren
zu krass gewann schnell an schon schnell
aber wir haben nicht viel ausgegeben
weil das dann auch viel außerdem gekauft
haben
ja auf jeden fall so einkaufen haben das
ist das ist die zuschauer ist das
vorhaben
deswegen habe sie auch drei war für die
nasen größten was sagen wir glauben ja
auch wert noch bei täglich wir haben für
bio äpfel kaufen wollen und dass bildung
es gibt auf jeden fall waffen mit
objekten mit dem topic apfelmus zwei man
wenn es hinten auch die fertigen
abfindungskosten werden genau das ist
sehr wichtig bio-eier bruder zucker eine
prise salz
wir haben sie auch halt in butter jetzt
so etwas dazu sagen jetzt das ist keine
zitronen in welcher form sie sind eine
sie teuer weil die unbehandelt ist die
hiesige wieder backpulver das ist dann
wollen wir die schmelzen
also wenn ich den jungen generation das
so als trompeter objekten ist günstig
schokostreuseln kaufen ihr habt die
chance dann noch mal obst für den faktor
ix weist er bei uns das bio mango so
jetzt guck mal die hat er nicht zwischen
kampfrichters ich habe angst einer
zucker und milch bo milch
das ist unser job wir brauchen hier
kommen wir machen das sowieso hat eine
schüssel ich kümmere mich um den teig
okay du und ich gucke durchschmilzt das
ganz gleich was du auch hier muss aber
alles auf dich mal zusammen geklebt
damit sie nicht wir wissen ganz genau
was da reinkommt
doch später mit es ist es egal was es an
zucker butter mutterboden und so wollte
und kakaobutter ursache ist wurde
wir dürfen auch nicht einmal nach dem
rezept google sondern dass das gebet wir
wissen einfach nicht
wanderwart wolfgang institute je 120
neben 1 422 hätten wir die etwas andere
schlüssel ist ja damals hat 20 gramm ein
bisschen mehr erstmal schlagen
habt ihr angst diese unterstellt wie
soll ich das einschalten butter und
zucker
es muss jetzt immer wahr sein oder das
geht doch gerade auf das muss das ist
für einen weg gibt es 33 kommt auch
massa com hatte merkt dass das bio ist
dann ist das ist geld das ist nicht so
lange
das ist die lager so markus bewusst wenn
wir zeit aber mehr mit dem chelsea hängt
ja alles
man merkt hier bei qvc das ist klar aber
die schüsse los sag mal mit dem
zeitfahren kiki kriegt ihr alles alles
braucht die ersten 20 der kunden die
jetzt anrufen gibt es das ist fertig wir
sagen weil ich gleich woher wissen sie
ganz genau
das benutzen wir damit das nicht
bröckelt er musste das jetzt können die
leute ja wir müssen wir haben mit
viktoria und wie viele backpulver oder
einen titel überlassen
also ich weiß ganz genau wie er gerade
augen zu machen
hier hilft recht ist das geht dann eine
jetzt wird es nochmals wird hier so
überkommt verfügung ist ja einfach geht
so jetzt gehen wir unser mehl und
puderzucker dazu genau so genau
doch nicht nur dass milch geben je nach
konsistenz alles klar
jahrhunderts
sie seien
der trakt landsleuten normalo für salz
das ist die serie also nach dem saal
erzählt dem geschmack herum ja das
glaube ich doch weil der mann zu einem
süßen rezeptors in der peter und zu
einem hertha bossen zu können die hier
richtig
ich finde er aber wenn ich erst unsere
top vorbereitet das so als topact sonst
wird das kleine kinder muss man aus der
küche so machen wir das noch mal keine
idee
das klingt logisch aber es ist nicht
einfach das haben wir für euch
überlassen
bre von ihrer macht einfach der
entscheidung musste also ich bin dafür
deutlich dass videos schneiden mussten
wenn ich dafür dass ich nicht
schätze mal und mensch ist ein
wir haben wir mehr arbeitet man haben
soll nächstens eigentlich so und der
ehemann von einer youtube-star person zu
sein
hast du jeden tag so viel zu essen ich
habe jeden tag mit viel zu essen ja aber
du musst du das essen ja da kann ich
nicht wirklich so krass genießen wie man
denkt weil manchmal feucht ist ja klar
du hast den stress das tut vorzubereiten
des videos zu drehen braucht ist ein
komma drin doch gesehen hatte gestern
aufgenommen und das ist halt immer so
ein bisschen stressig naja ich kannst du
es immer noch essen aber du hast dich
diese humorvoll bis zu ersten mal zu
probieren
ich weiß nicht er war ein bisschen zu
tode ist immer zucker rein und sagen wir
mal einem stabmixer durch das gute ist
der topf ist stabil und gut also ist es
kein sommer ist der kreis möchte ich
komme und das wird nicht so auch glaube
ich bin zuversichtlich da musst du ein
gewisses manko muss ich überhaupt kochen
zu hause nur 1
du merkst nennen ich werde ich gut weil
sie in theorie hab ich drauf der praxis
überhaupt debatte unter 600 sich das
schreiben kann der kasse passiert jetzt
ja wo ist denn die kirche ist voll war
der küche nein das heißt was passieren
könnte ist das wasser getrieben
wir müssen wir die mädels müssen dass
gewinne es nicht mehr
du bist der hobbits harmlos die haben da
weißt du ich das sowieso aufgenommen
warum also richtig und jetzt stellt das
nicht ein professionelles video als
person ist auf jeden fall ich werde also
keine bleiben diese männer kennen nur
eine sache auf eine nacht ins feld wir
können viel verstehen also das war es
und das lesen und dabei es heißt
schmecken
die marke bisschen mehr zu tun doch das
tat es weil das ist genau ihr geschmack
des wahnsinns oder wir wollen hier auch
zitrone ab wir machen das hier weil
sonst ist ja nicht so dass wir haben ja
das ist jetzt habt ihr nicht vergessen
ja ich weiß dass unverletzt
das war für alle schöne waren schon so
die hat schon die erste wache gebracht
und gemacht und so das was sie dabei
erleben sie sofort an einer schlechten
ersten mal vergessen damals benutzten
klar was aber nicht zu viel mehr geht
nicht einfach nein nein
was hast du extra zum bruder sich ja als
ob ich den schwarzen peter wie viel
schreien klatschen
hey ich hab ich habe eine wette verloren
wird das spiel verloren
ich musste einen teelöffel zimt dessen
ich mache das nie wieder einmal
eine woche einen halt schweiz inhaltlich
zum glück ist es kommen gute straße aber
die flugbereitschaft
ich glaube der guten augen schauen ich
glaube im ganztag sollten das als
letztes video machen
er kommt jetzt auch so machen classic
dem automatisch verwischt die erste
wacken ist immer so mehrere züge knapp
aber ich glaube das ist das ist nichts
das muss flüssiger sagen da hab ich ja
wenn die lager sagt ich bin euer zeigt
ist gut dann ist unser täglich konstanz
gut das was ihr sagt ich glaube da muss
man jetzt auch viel zu viel zu viel mit
transparentem als kanal 10 95
so reicht es wirklich die reden das ist
ja dass davon saß den opfern
das laufen werde tun was wir als sprint
formel 1 keine dass wir gerade draußen
das doch besser den überschuss mitnehmen
kurz gesagt wir brauchten kjg die presse
den ersten 30 kann man jetzt auch das
stimmt ja auch räumlich nah dran haben
die verhindert dass er so gefallen
wussten wir sagt jetzt nochmals
augenschein märkischen alter 888 mal
egal ob das aber wir brauchen hier gibt
es nicht vielleicht sei nie von den test
waffe leihen
er widmete der weg klar dieses das
gleiten
ich bin echt mal heißt es warmes wasser
müssen sich das mal nein du hast einfach
die kinder einfach auf die mauern eines
gärtner von mario assmann die zum
schmelzen da gibt es eintopf tut man
wasser ein
dann kocht das und kurzem habe ich
mitgemacht habe ich recht du weißt dass
du nicht kommentieren man das aber nicht
da hier kannst du das auch mal dass mit
meinem sekunden sicher
also eigentlich kann sie nach hause
so können wir das somit dann natürlich
wenn nicht ich weiß aber sie sollte aber
das macht mal mit viel lieber kam sah
einfach die show kosten aber es hätte
ich doch aufgehoben ich war das nicht
gemeint ich hätte das nicht gesehen und
ich erstmal durchatmen so was dann
passierte das ist der stürmer das ist
auch die gute aufstellung
das ist nicht meine 54 zwar genannte
meine meinung dass neben 452 geht ganz
ruhig mal nicht so toll das ist hart
geworden das sieht doch gut aus
spaß beiseite krieg oder das doch wir
haben noch die chance ich glaub ich
glaube wir haben ich glaube wir haben
eine ganze reihe oder muss ich glaube
das reicht nicht das ist doch nur ein
bisschen zulegen
das ist politiker können selbst ich weiß
das ist das weiße schokolade mit einem
waffe da draußen
dafür läuft können wir mal mit silber
die 70 angeordneten chance reden die
chance über wasser war dann wirklich
geschlossen hast du so heißt eine
feuerfeste wir brauchen eine feuerfeste
schale
ich kann ich auch einen projektor damit
auch ja egal wir machen einfach
kreissprecher minister selbst gemachten
muss macht und wenn es aufgeschäumt ist
dann nicht mehr weiter wächst weil dann
jetzt wieder
da die mutter
wenn ich gar nicht da ich jetzt mal dass
wir grund geben unser highlight ist das
ding wollte spritzbeutel spritzbeutel
sind töne ohne schäden für die spitze
vorne wegschneiden
jetzt wäre aus als ich gemerkt habe ich
hoffe sie kommt die optik die über das
sprint ich hasse bereut
das sieht schon wurde das aber auch dass
mir das nicht einfach ist das nicht
schön aus und das ist auch verständlich
die katastrophe wäre hier mal daran auch
in zeitlupe keine bund bekommen weil wir
keine kinder finden das ist banal mit
krokant und jobs schaffen und das rad
also ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht wieso
aber wir gewinnen so trägt noch einmal
jetzt müsst ihr wie beim us wirtschaft
noch einmal begründen warum was sie
gemacht hat sondern man sozial sowie
sagen wir so ich ja ich hab hoffe ihr
wagen geschoben hätte gross gemacht also
die gäste machen
also man hat gemerkt bei diesem tag dass
die chemie stimmt so ja unsere stimmen
also habe ich ihn unter nicht aufgepasst
weil banken ist chemie chemie fifa 20
auf jeden fall können die teams schon
wieder fifa gemacht aber das nicht wir
haben auf jeden fall hier reicht muss
sagen die dekorativen also da habe ich
nichts zu tun
wir waren zu anfang optimistisch wir da
hatten wir kriegen das bot ihm die waffe
langweilig relativ gut hinbekommen
meiner meinung nach die optik passt
einfach nicht so dass ich zu gehen ich
hoffe der geschmack passt aber dafür
also ich finde ihr müsst alles gemüse
alt und palettenweise persönlich
geschickt hat er hat durch die wesen
atelier bananen das weberhaus kein
bestimmt ja okay ich weiß auch wie
schmeckt dann offenbar selbst hält die
genossenschaft was immer abnehmen musste
ja emma und bananen
was jetzt hier restaurant festen
partnerschaft der abtritt er sorgt für
kommt heute sehr dominant ich konnte
also 1 das gleiche funktioniert ich bin
ehrlich sachsen die schlimmer
vorgestellt
die konsistente sind irgendwie nicht so
auch wieder sein können
da schlägt einfach aber ein freies und
ich muss es ja ein ding ist auf jeden
fall eine frage habe nicht wo er ist
ich hab doch nichts gemacht hat ehrlich
wir haben
erzählt wir haben wollten uns jemand in
der zweiten abteilung 2008 selber in dem
land nach kopfform einkaufen auch selber
schon vorher sind die besten aktiven
mache jetzt erst so lange braucht er
jedes mal gibt es ahs kosten gemacht
haben wie man an der kosten würde ich
weiß was ich was macht sie gucken da
haben wir sehr dass uns und sagt weißt
du was tempo ist hoch denn doch noch
besser talentierten das management geht
disqualifiziert weil ein comeback auf
nicht das ganze gebäude kaufen
ich kaufe das gehofft werden dabei ich
habe hier in dieser kassen zu
römerzeiten also an eigentliche externen
ist bei mir aber kommende woche in
bremen ist nicht mehr das was der
minister
ich hab schon so verkauft aber was meint
ihr denn die sonne das mitleid haben
oder er nicht irgendwann kurze beine und
sparten ist ein camp der mit seinem
roller von jal schloss sich jetzt auch
dass wir raus und es fällt schnee die
mengen keine arbeit also nach schwerer
sechs einschlagen
zu viel zucker reicht also deswegen
leiten sich die banker haben die
zuschauer schon so gekauft also das 60
die jungs haben schon vorgelegt jetzt
sind wir dran sind wir wie vor nehme ich
also ganz ehrlich ich war überrascht
dass du das bedeutet also dass stand was
am ende auf dem teller das fand ich
krass aber geschmacklich finde ich nicht
so wir fangen jetzt an werden wir wollen
ihnen direkt eine dicke wir wollen wir
dann mit unseren waffen rätsel wir
machen das um vage oder sind sich die
hosen auch dann keine hoffnung gemacht
aber es ist der fehler gerade war bei
den jungs die haben das habt ihr gemacht
wir haben butter und eier direkt
zusammen aufgeschlagen okay dann
stichwahl mutter alleine mit sowas kann
es eben schon viel und sie glauben also
dass würde glaube ich reichen ja und was
sie bemerken wir dass wir mit mit zucker
das war der fehler gerade mache ich noch
vergessen unsere sein werden die gekauft
habe doch gibt also erst müssen wir ja
butter mit zucker cremig schlagen und
danach kommen erst die eierei nach 34
minuten erst was man sieht ich weiß ja
was ich mache ich warte auf meine
eigenen wir machen auch einen shop in
shop und suchen ja jetzt müssen wir das
schlagen genau jetzt schlagen wir das
darf ich das mal dass sollen nutzer
hoffen rauskommen nehmen wir einen ein
wir übertreiben nicht so wie die jungs
der erste direkte waffeln oder so
gemacht und realistischer machen wir
zwei kannst du das machen
gleichzeitig war mir immer wieder die
sachen weg so dass einmal ein
ja ja ja hallo
so jetzt haben wir hier das backpulver
auch die kamera wechseln müssen die
überhitzten weil hier übertrieben habt
hier in der kirche perfekt dann würde
ich sagen dass es abwechselnd wie der
milch reingeben ok immer wieder mich
dazwischen und der wurde so viel zucker
angemacht werde ich noch kirchenrecht
besser noch zu flüssig also wo der teig
wird schon mal richtig gut aus ein
extrakt jetzt genau exakt das ist ja
unser joker hat sondern 18 reinhauen
dass man übertreibt nicht so wie haben
sie denn kleine menge reicht eigentlich
schon aufpassen und einer macht parallel
menschen dafür dass die kirchen malz war
das kann ich nicht aber bald kann habe
ich überlegt wir machen waffeln
so richtig klassisch pläne 110 im
restaurant ja sonst bei uns ist die
sache ich hatte schon in meinem kopf ist
das dekor ihre bevor ich hier so ging es
mir ich hab dann hoffe ich dass der
kurier bevor wir überhaupt die zutaten
ja hier haben wir jetzt so einen
messbecher der ist von dem waffeleisen
das haben die jungs nämlich auch nicht
gesehen und das steht die mengenangabe
wie viel benutzten soll
wenn ihr das nicht da habt einfach
normal leben
es ist so harmonisch hier so viele
mitglieder recht entspannt
die lage ist keine typische ich mich ja
profi voller und jetzt eben gemacht wenn
ich das jetzt so sehe bei mir also ich
mache das hier die kirschen sind jetzt
noch flüssig daher heute sagen
kein applaus keine 40 knoten
speisestärke mit auch kein zucker die
wahrscheinlich genug gesagt einen hut
bringt ohne alkohol ihr steht sogar die
minute gelang es braucht ja das ist geil
siehst du das läuft auch nicht an den
seiten aus ja wer nämlich eine
schieferplatte ich bin sauber das
probiere ich doch mal wissen wie die
schmecken zu den gästen
dort kam heute große reichte oder man
muss sich also im übermaß haben haben
wir uns die heißen kirschen da rennt
kugelbahnen auf die andere seite
die sahne auf die waffe eigentlich nur
hier zum dekorieren die übernahme ja
genau habe ich auch gedacht ich wollte
jetzt auf die erste schon mal so ein
bisschen mehr leben jetzt kommt meine
besonderheit der tricks raus jetzt hast
du das machen
also ich weiss nicht sicher
fertig fünf minuten genau aussieht
mit einsatz gemacht 100 euro douglas
williams müssen wir das geld nicht
kriegen sie von mir sehr gut okay okay
dass wir noch geil 100 euro douglas
gutschein stück von bayern zweistöckig
verlosen
was ist dafür tun dass mir der folge auf
uns sein
hier folgen auf youtube auch ja ohne
sich für die abonnenten gewerkt klar auf
jeden fall dass ihr und kommentieren
sollen ja ja nein nein besonders
kompliziert es ist ein kommen hier
täglich machen für welche waffe schöner
ich bin ja echt geschaut wie schnell das
gerade echt ging ob es ging weniger
strom
das ist aus brüssel ist können zum
kaffee servieren jahrhundert erstmals
selbst muss mir ja ich bei der verlosung
gerne mitmachen von der spontanen aktion
steckt auf jeden fall die das kann jeder
aber große wende welche ich euch auch
noch wohnt aufschreiben und natürlich
auch bei den hörnchen ausschließen
also schön war's ja hab ich auch so
gewollt bis zum nächsten mal